Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg will
testify in front of a joint hearing of
the Senate Judiciary and commerce
committees today it starts two days of
testimony on Capitol Hill senators will
demand answers from Zuckerberg about
Facebook's failure to protect millions
of users private information a new CBS
News YouGov poll in the wake of
Cambridge of the Cambridge analytical
scandal finds 51 percent of Americans
consider Facebook's response
unacceptable 63 percent of Facebook
users believe their data is unsafe Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with a look at
today's hearing Nancy good morning good
morning John they've actually added
extra seats to this hearing room to
accommodate all the Senators who are
going to be questioning Zuckerberg today
44 of them that's nearly half the Senate
and they're each going to get about four
to five minutes with him so it means
that Zuckerberg is going to be in the
hot seat for hours after getting an
earful in private yesterday in a dry run
of sorts Mark Zuckerberg went from
office to office Monday meeting with
four top senators Florida Democrat Bill
Nelson talked with him for over an hour
he sees that mistakes have been made and
pelted him with the kinds of questions
he's sure to get today the message I
wanted to convey to him that if we don't
rein in the misuse of social media none
of us are going to have any privacy
anymore
Facebook says it has gotten that message
on Monday it began notifying up to 87
million users whose data was improperly
accessed by political consulting firm
Cambridge analytical did he say why
Facebook never told anyone about this he
did not according to his prepared
remarks Zuckerberg will admit today we
didn't take a broad enough view of our
responsibility and that was a big
mistake we have a responsibility to not
just build tools but to make sure those
tools are used for good Facebook has
been slow to take needed steps to make
changes to its platform senators on the
left and right want to know more today
about the other companies that facebook
says may also have harvest
personal information from some of its
more than two billion users I don't know
if Facebook knows who has my data
Facebook says well we're going to do
better going forward but my data is out
there and God knows who hasn't consumer
privacy rights organizations are
planning protests here on Capitol Hill
and outside Facebook headquarters in
California during today's testimony as
for that Cambridge analytic a data
incursion Nora the company says it plans
to notify all users about whether their
information was accessed in the coming
days a lot of seats there Nancy thank
you so much